We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David P..
Here's something interesting. There's this
Trumpy right winger, Troy Yawk, who's been
calling into the show for years. And this is sort
of like a last salvo from Troy, York, as Donald
Trump is done and Joe Biden becomes president,
very confused, maybe sort of dejected and just
spreading a lot of disinformation. Let's listen
to a little bit of it. OK, take a listen to this.
You know, why do you keep saying that red states
are the leeches and blue states paying some more
money? Well, because that's true. Talking about
blue states costs more with the pension costs.
OK, so that said that now that blue
states cost more with pension costs,
that has nothing to do with what I
was talking about. The frame here
is that if there were to be a civil war or a
secession now, unlike during the civil war,
things are less clearly defined
because cities are overwhelmingly left,
whereas rural areas are overwhelmingly right.
But that if you can come up with a sort of
traditional blue state, red state, split the
country, that would be made up of American
red states would be completely unsustainable
financially, because as we know when it comes
to federal funds paid in by states or paid out to
states, the blue states subsidize the red states.
This has nothing to do with state pensions,
the cost for storing and locking up criminals,
the costs of big government.
Why do you keep saying that?
The cost of big government. Yeah,
it doesn't really sound like Troy
York knows what he's talking about.
Red states are more sustainable. They can
actually take care of themselves, produce food.
And and again, all of that is very wrong. I mean,
food is an interesting one. There's no doubt that
many red and purple states are big food producers.
But you need only look at the top food producers
of the country to see that California produces
twice as much food as any other state.
And then if you look at the top 10,
there's a bunch of purple and blue states there.
You've got California, Minnesota and Illinois
are top food growers. Wisconsin is a top food
grower. So, yeah, sure, many red states produce
a lot of food, but it is not at all clear that
that they produce more than the blue state on
every one of these things. Troyes is just wrong.
Blue states are the ones that are country in debt.
Very much untrue and are mismanaged
and are not financially feasible.
Yeah, I mean, so that's literally the opposite of
the truth as we have. We've looked at many times.
There are many more red states that without
being on federal welfare, essentially money
from the federal government, there are many blue
states that would be sustainable. There are very
few red states that would. And I don't know that
the facts really matter to a lot of these folks.
And that's why tomorrow we will be going through
in detail or Friday. It depends if I have time.
A very interesting right wing focus group with
Trump voters done by Frank Luntz. We have a
fantastic bonus show today and it's Inauguration
Day. It may already have happened by the time
you listen to today's show tomorrow, full wall
to wall coverage of the Joe Biden inauguration
of the Trumpy and right wing meltdown of the
future of Joe Biden's day one priorities.
Yes, we will be covering them and so much more
get instant access to The David Pakman Show
membership program and today's great bonus
show by signing up at Join Pakman Dotcom.